Il y a un super article dans le magazine « The Atlantic »
écrit par Paul Barnwell, un professeur de lycée.
Ses élèves ont fait un projet de communication.
Il voulait leur apprendre à parler d'un sujet particulier sans notes.
Il a dit ceci : « Je me suis rendu compte... »
(Rires)
« Je me suis rendu compte que l'aptitude à tenir une conversation
est peut-être la compétence qu'on néglige le plus d'enseigner.
Les enfants passent des heures à dialoguer et émettre des idées via des écrans,
mais ils ont rarement l'opportunité
d'affiner leurs compétences de communication interpersonnelles.
Ça peut sembler bizarre, mais on doit se demander :
au XXIème siècle, quelle compétence
est plus importante que de savoir tenir une conversation cohérente ?
Mon métier est de parler aux gens :
des lauréats du Prix Nobel, des routiers,
des milliardaires, des professeurs en maternelle,
des chefs d’État, des plombiers.
Je parle à des gens que j'apprécie et à d'autres que je n'apprécie pas.
Je parle à des gens avec lesquels je suis profondément en désaccord.
Mais j'ai toujours de fantastiques conversations avec eux.
Pendant les 10 prochaines minutes, j'aimerais vous apprendre à parler
et à écouter.
Nombre d'entre vous ont déjà entendu des conseils à ce sujet :
regarder les gens dans les yeux,
réfléchir au préalable à des sujets intéressants à aborder,
regarder, hocher la tête et sourire pour montrer votre attention,
répéter ce que vous avez entendu ou le résumer.
Oubliez tout cela.
C'est de la merde.
(Rires)
Il n'y a pas de raison d'apprendre à démontrer que vous êtes attentif,
si vous êtes effectivement attentif.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'utilise exactement les mêmes compétences en tant qu'intervieweuse professionnelle
que dans ma vie quotidienne.
Je vais donc vous apprendre à questionner les gens
et ça va vous aider à apprendre comment être de meilleurs communicants.
Apprenez à avoir une conversation
sans perdre votre temps, sans vous ennuyer,
et surtout, sans offenser quiconque.
Nous avons tous déjà eu des conversations extraordinaires.
Nous en avons eues. Nous savons ce que c'est.
Le genre de conversation qui vous fait vous sentir impliqué et inspiré,
ou qui vous donne l'impression d'avoir vraiment créer un lien,
ou d'avoir été parfaitement compris.
Il n'y a pas de raison
que la majorité de nos conversations ne soient pas ainsi.
J'ai 10 règles de base. Je vais vous les expliquer
mais honnêtement, si vous en prenez une et la maîtrisez pleinement,
vous aurez déjà de meilleures conversations.
Numéro 1 : pas de multitâche.
Pas seulement poser son portable,
sa tablette ou ses clés de voiture, ou ce que vous avez en main.
Soyez présent.
Vivez dans l'instant.
Ne pensez pas à la dispute avec votre patron,
ni à ce que vous allez manger ce soir.
Si vous voulez terminer la conversation,
faites-le,
mais ne soyez pas qu'à moitié présent.
Numéro 2 : ne donnez pas de leçon.
Si vous voulez donner votre opinion,
sans aucune opportunité de répondre, discuter, réagir ou grandir,
écrivez un blog.
(Rires)
J'ai une très bonne raison de ne pas inviter de critiques à mon émission :
ils sont très ennuyeux.
Les conservateurs vont détester Obama, les timbres alimentaires et l'avortement.
Les libéraux vont détester
les grandes banques, l'industrie du pétrole et Dick Cheney.
Complètement prévisible.
Vous ne voulez pas être ainsi.
Vous devez entamer chaque conversation,
avec l'idée que vous allez apprendre quelque chose.
Scott Peck, le célèbre thérapeute, a dit
que pour une vraie écoute, il faut s'effacer.
Ça veut dire parfois mettre de côté sa propre opinion.
Il a dit que l'orateur sentira cette acceptation,
et deviendra de moins en moins vulnérable
et offrira plus probablement les recoins cachés de son esprit
à celui qui écoute.
Considérez que vous avez des choses à apprendre.
Bill Nye : « Chaque personne sait une chose que vous ignorez. »
Je le dis ainsi :
chaque personne est un expert en quelque chose.
Numéro 3 : Posez des questions ouvertes.
Pour ça, inspirez-vous des journalistes.
Commencez vos questions avec qui, quoi, quand, où, pourquoi ou comment.
Si vous posez une question complexe, la réponse sera simple.
Si je vous demande : « Étiez-vous terrifié ? »
vous allez répondre au mot le plus puissant de cette phrase,
ici « terrifié », et la réponse sera oui ou non.
« Étiez-vous en colère ? » « Oui, très en colère. »
Laissez-les décrire. C'est eux qui savent.
Posez des questions telles que : « C'était comment ? »
« Qu'avez-vous ressenti ? »
Car ils pourraient avoir besoin d'un moment de réflexion
et vous aurez alors une réponse bien plus intéressante.
Numéro 4 : suivez le flot.
Ça veut dire que des idées vont vous venir à l'esprit
et que vous devez les laisser sortir de votre esprit.
Nous avons souvent entendu des interviews
où l'invité parle pendant plusieurs minutes,
puis l'animateur reprend la parole et pose une question
qui semble sortir de nulle part, ou à laquelle il a déjà été répondu.
L'animateur a probablement arrêté d'écouter 2 minutes auparavant
car il réfléchissait à sa prochaine question,
une question très intelligente qu'il était déterminé à poser.
Nous faisons la même chose.
Nous sommes assis, en train de discuter avec quelqu'un,
puis on se souvient de notre rencontre avec Hugh Jackman dans un café.
(Rires)
On arrête d'écouter.
Des histoires et idées vont vous venir.
Vous devez les laisser venir, puis repartir.
Numéro 5 : si vous ne savez pas, dites que vous ne savez pas.
Les gens à la radio, particulièrement sur NPR,
ont plus conscience que ce qu'ils disent est enregistré ;
ils sont donc plus prudents quand ils évoquent leur expertise
et ce qu'ils sont sûrs de savoir.
Faites pareil. Pêchez par excès de prudence.
La parole ne devrait pas être prise à la légère.
Numéro 6 : ne comparez pas votre expérience à la leur.
S'ils parlent de la perte d'un membre de leur famille,
ne parlez pas de la perte d'un membre de votre famille.
S'ils parlent des problèmes qu'ils ont au travail,
ne leur dites pas que vous détestez votre travail.
Ce n'est pas la même chose, jamais.
Toute expérience est unique.
Plus important encore, il n'est pas question de vous.
Pas besoin d'utiliser ce moment pour prouver que vous êtes génial
ou à quel point vous avez souffert.
Quelqu'un a demandé son QI à Stephen Hawking, qui a répondu :
« Aucune idée. Ceux qui se vantent de leur QI sont des nuls. »
(Rires)
Les conversations ne sont pas des opportunités promotionnelles.
Numéro 7 :
essayez de ne pas vous répéter.
C'est condescendant et très ennuyeux
et nous avons tendance à le faire.
Particulièrement lors de conversations au travail,
ou avec nos enfants,
nous avons un message à passer
alors nous le reformulons inlassablement.
Ne le faites pas.
Numéro 8 : épargnez les détails.
Franchement, peu importe
les années, les noms,
les dates et tous ces détails
dont vous n'arrivez pas à vous rappeler.
Peu importe. Ce qui importe c'est vous.
Les gens s'intéressent à vous,
à ce que vous avez en commun.
Oubliez les détails. Laissez-les de côté.
Numéro 9 :
ce n'est pas la dernière, mais c'est la plus importante.
Écoutez.
Je ne peux pas vous dire combien de personnes importantes ont dit
qu'écouter est peut-être la compétence la plus importante à développer.
Bouddha a dit, et je paraphrase :
« Si votre bouche est ouverte, vous n'apprenez pas. »
Et Calvin Collidge a dit : « Personne n'a jamais été viré pour avoir écouté. »
(Rires)
Pourquoi ne nous écoutons-nous pas ?
Premièrement, nous préférons parler.
Quand je parle, j'ai le contrôle.
Je n'ai pas à entendre ce qui ne m'intéresse pas.
Je suis le centre de l'attention.
Je peux mettre en avant mon identité.
Mais il n'y a pas que ça :
nous nous laissons distraire.
Nous prononçons en moyenne 225 mots par minute,
mais pouvons en écouter jusqu'à 500.
Donc nos esprits complètent avec 275 autres mots.
Je sais qu'il faut des efforts et de l'énergie
pour accorder notre attention à quelqu'un,
mais si vous ne le faites pas, ce n'est pas une conversation,
mais plutôt deux personnes criant des phrases à peines connexes
dans un même lieu.
(Rires)
Vous devez vous écouter l'un l'autre.
Stephen Covey l'a très bien dit :
« Nombre d'entre nous n'écoutent pas pour comprendre.
Nous écoutons pour répondre. »
Une dernière règle, numéro 10 : soyez bref.
[Une bonne conversation c'est comme une mini-jupe :
assez courte pour retenir l'attention,
et assez longue pour couvrir le sujet. -- Ma sœur]
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Tout ça revient à un concept de base :
intéressez-vous aux autres.
J'ai grandi avec un grand-père très célèbre
et il y avait un rituel chez moi.
Les gens venaient parler à mes grands-parents
et après qu'ils soient partis, ma mère venait nous voir
et disait : « Vous savez qui c'était ?
C'était la finaliste de Miss Amérique.
C'était le maire de Sacramento.
Elle a gagné un prix Pulitzer. C'est un danseur de ballet russe. »
J'ai grandi donc en croyant
que tout le monde a un côté caché et tout à fait génial.
Je crois que ça fait de moi une meilleure animatrice.
Je garde la bouche fermée autant que possible,
je garde l'esprit ouvert
et je suis toujours prête à être ébahie
et je ne suis jamais déçue.
Faites de même.
Allez parler aux gens,
écoutez-les,
et, surtout, soyez prêt à être ébahi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)